i know that there was like a um
i don't know like a weird uh energy
between you and yay and then it was dope
to see you guys kind of get back
together um
around the time that the donda king's
king's disease [ __ ] was happening um
really like uh linking up with game like
i linked up with him top of january and
we just started cutting
after we after like three days we
probably had like 11 12 joints and it
was a one joint in particular i was like
yo you need to have yay pull up the
chalice so we can get him on this joint
we end up playing a bunch of stuff and
easy was one of the ideas that game had
already had and as soon as uh
kanye had um heard the easy part he
tapped me like yo this like this the one
basically and how he ended up hopping on
it that was something that uh him and
the homie duke duke is fire dude crazy
straight you know saying shout out ohio
to homies also duke could also be he's
also a security slash producer that
guy's that guy's a mountain of a man
yeah i've been on duke for a minute yeah
these game sessions were crazy because i
remember going to um listen to like he
invited me to the studio
and
it was you know we know how studio
sessions are and they're not like how
people think they are yeah like you know
if you tell your girl you're going to
the studio and she doesn't know better
she's gonna think there's a bunch of
hoes and a bunch of [ __ ] going on
yeah and it's not like that right well
these sessions were definitely like that
there are they are 100 rapper sessions
it was some real vintage i call it club
games it was club [ __ ] it's a whole
bottle it's a bar
but the crazy thing is is he's in there
knocking out four or five songs a
nightmare he's in there focused it's
crazy no matter what's going on never
have 100 people in my session and get
all this done so i mean applaud to him
and just i think it's crazy how many uh
beats do you have on the drill matic
project that's coming out on the 17th oh
no because i know they're trying to
clear samples and i don't know what's
going to clear what's not we use a bunch
of samples so we're going to see was
that like
you you and game did you guys ever work
together previously yeah i worked on the
red um okay yeah i did some [ __ ] on
there so we always was tapped in and we
we we had other joints but just nothing
that ever came out and then uh we just
tapped in top of the year right after
magic came out it was just a energy in
the air so he pulled up and at first it
was just like us just in the stool
for you know three four days and we
knocked out a bunch of stuff and after
that he got inspired and he was like man
i'm about to start booking my own room
and he just turned it in the club yeah
he booked that room across from you yeah
that shit's crazy game had played me
some [ __ ] probably like late last year
this is before he started working at
chalice and he had like what i guess he
considered his album some of it was dope
um
but then the [ __ ] that he was working on
at chalice was just crazy it was like a
whole new energy i can't even tell you
how many songs he got because i know
just between me and him we got about 30
something songs so i'm like he didn't
had a hundred producers in here he must
have two three hundred songs like yeah
really go like that so once kanye pulled
up to to cut his because we all saw the
footage of him at the studio was that
like where you guys kind of really had
like a a moment
to kind of move past whatever energy had
been
i mean yeah at least for that moment for
sure it was dope like um i was able to
after you know we was in game room i was
like bro you got to come into my room
and just bless the energy like you know
nipsey been in there and i was getting
there
so many people i'm like i gotta have you
pull up and he pulled up i was able to
play him a couple beats and we was
vibing but we haven't connected on
anything else yet